bonjour estelle vous êtes devant le
bâtiment de l'association des maires de
france les maires qui ont donc jusqu'à
midi pour se prononcer si oui ou non ils
peuvent en tout cas organiser ces
élections départementales et régionales
en juin prochain
oui la question leur a été adressé par
les préfets oui ou non les conditions
préconisé par le conseil scientifique
sont elles réunies pour tenir les deux
scrutins du mois de juin c'est donc vous
l'avez dit magali à cette question a que
les maires de france ont été sommés de
répondre une consultation en vue du
débat parlementaire qui devrait s'ouvrir
demain et qui portera donc sur la
question du maintien ou non des
élections le conseil scientifique à lui
émis une série de recommandations en cas
de maintien du scrutin il préconise par
exemple de solliciter les personnes
vaccinées pour la tenue des bureaux
il suggère aussi que le vote se fasse en
extérieur et puis enfin il préconise un
nettoyage strict des établissements
mobilisés et du côté des réactions
estelle il ya cette consultation qui a
du mal à passer
et puis la question du report qui divise
bien sûr
oui la consultation passe mal a commencé
chez les premiers intéressés en les
maires cet avis ne serait faire porter
aux maires la responsabilité d'une
décision à qui relève entièrement de
celle de l'état peut-on lire dans un
communiqué de la mf l'association des
maires de france présidée par françois
baroin plusieurs élus ont dénoncé ce
qu'ils appellent une instrumentalisation
à des mères c'est le cas par exemple du
président du groupe ps au sc n'a
réaction aussi un sur la question
centrale à savoir le maintien ou non
donc des scrutins gérard larcher par
exemple le président du sénat qui s'est
prononcé pour le maintien est des
élections a prévenu si le gouvernement
présentait un projet de loi pour les
reporter il saisirait le conseil
constitutionnel son homologue à
l'assemblée nationale richard ferrand
lui
elle s'est dite en faveur d'un report du
scrutin tout comme par exemple le maire
à l'est républicain de nice christian
estrosi pour qui la seule campagne qui
doit prévaloir est la campagne vaccinale
et non électorale vous l'aurez compris
magali le débat est donc loin d'être
tranché ouais on verra cela à midi donc
l'ultimatum lancé par l'exécutif pour se
prononcer pour que les mères dit si oui
ou non ces élections doivent se tenir en
juin ou pas on verra cela merci beaucoup
estelle en direct du siège de la fff à
paris